avec ses 2 mètre vingt d'envergure et
son bec jaune ce pig arc de stellaire ne
passe pas inaperçu dans les allées du
parc forestier animalier de l'espace
rambouillet c'est l'une des espèces les
plus rares du site c'est aigle
originaire de l'est de la russie est
actuellement menacé et a vu sa
population passer de 15000 à 6000
individus qu'il est de plus en plus
rares parce que quand je les lis un
aigle aux pêcheurs qui se nourrit
beaucoup de poissons je savais que dans
les pays de l'est il ya beaucoup de
compagnies pétrolières et gazières qui
s'installe et qui rejette
malheureusement beaucoup de métaux
lourds et de produits chimiques dans les
dents les grands fleuves donc comme lui
il est en fin de chaîne alimentaire ils
en pâtit le premier couple est arrivé en
1995 à rambouillet et qu'en 2003 les
premières naissances ces programmes sont
menées en concertation avec la russie
dans les années 1994 l'état russe a
décidé de prélever des individus dans le
milieu naturel comme la population était
en fort déclin
ils ont prélevé un certain nombre
d'individus pour les pour les mettre en
parc zoologique à travers le monde
et l'objectif est de créer une
population captive viable pour peut-être
un jour les réintroduire dans le milieu
naturel
aujourd'hui on compte plus d'une
vingtaine de naissance de cette espèce
au sein de la structure ces oiseaux sont
visibles par le public à travers les
volières ou bien les spectacles c'est
surtout sensibiliser le grand public à
la cause des rapaces à la disparition
des espèces à la protection de ces
oiseaux
donc on accueille à peu près 50 mille
scolaires
donc on vraiment un rôle de donner des
informations sur ce qui se passe dehors
au total le parc oeuvre dans la
préservation d'une quarantaine d'espèces
de rapaces présentes sur le site
les responsables encadrés naissance et
est de la réintroduction cbb chouette de
l'oural vont être transférés d'ici la mi
juin dans leur milieu naturel
ils sont emmenés en bavière en allemagne